A day in my life as a tribewife content creator
what people think edition.
I wake up at about 11:00am.
After sleeping in,
I checked my phone
and the algorithm smiled favorably upon me last night,
I've gained 50,000 followers since I last checked my phone at 2:00am.
Since I am the main bread winner,
my husband makes us a gourmet breakfast
while I give him his to do list for today.
We have two videos to make for brands,
and while my husband doesn't really like to be on camera,
I'm the boss, and these brands are paying me $20,000 a video.
After breakfast,
I get dressed in my Tread Wife cosplay
and we get started filming the first video.
Our goal here is to look like a happy couple in love,
which is hard,
but honestly, I'm so good at acting that no one even questions it.
After we film the videos,
I change into a, like,
normal outfit
and we take our Mercedes to the dealership to get an oil change
and get dinner at a five star restaurant
where three people recognized me and asked for my autograph.
Being an influencer is so hard,
I wish I was just like a normal person.